how's it going brahs welcome to prized
input by the best show on the entire
universe on a Friday maybe for this
week's amazing episode I'm gonna do
something original and that no one ever
else would achieve
we're dead we're gonna do a Q&A I'm like
a 40 year old mom trying to deal with
her [ __ ] while a baby's being annoying
Jess Jess da I for one can't wait to see
what questions you bros have for me for
this episode eat my ass I would gladly
eat your ass but that's not a question
idiot so no stop stop I swear to God
next question Sam pine Mike's question
you're an ugly woman next question can
you do a Q&A with vast beautiful they're
all I love louis Tomlinson or I love one
Direction's dick will you ever bring
back Alice madness Returns all right so
this was a series that I did know to
tweet two years ago we never finish it
because I lost my say final no I won't i
won't go back and replay eight hours
just to finish it I'm sorry please
continue serious for my always up I wish
Alice from Alice madness Returns was you
I will at least that I could finish the
[ __ ] game please finish Jesus Christ
where you really continued just it's not
gonna happen I'm sorry I tried so hard
nice question it's my friend's birthday
today and she's a huge pit of - so we
put your face all over the room it seems
more like a prank than something nice
but happy birthday I hope you enjoy your
wall this is actually a very impressive
altar to pray to your Lord and Savior
sampai probably ask this a lot but you
should finish Alan Jesus crop this is
the worst Q&A ever
what happened I can't do anything normal
with you bros Zayn Malik Soares of
course all my fans are One Direction
people who just wants to [ __ ] with me
this is where we are right now Katrina
Perez asked will you ever read this no
just Shh that all the questions are you
[ __ ] kidding me no no this there's
more don't worry do you like bubbles no
I hate I hate them [ __ ] stupid like
your [ __ ] question I'm sorry Claire
I'm all bubbles why don't you play your
guitar for a few minutes oh that's out
of tune
well [ __ ] it then will you join my
minecraft server um yes I love minecraft
I wish my entire channel was based
around it so I could just play minecraft
all day but I'm not blessed I'm doomed
to play [ __ ] games instead
are you my dad no please stop calling me
Dad
I would really appreciate it it's
[ __ ] weird it's weirding me out
everyone thinks you're weird people
think I'm weird it's not a good weird
it's it's just weird
stop thank if you were a Disney Princess
what princess would you be Thomas the
princess
just Carrie it's me don't worry yeah
that looks good how do you smell so nice
in your videos it's been on my mind for
a long time it's a combination between
sweat from all the lightening equipment
that's on me and Edgar's farts what's
your favorite who's moans coast shut the
lot of Avatar this mode what do you
think is the thing weirder than the
internet your grammar are you still a
virgin yes and I also still live with my
mom if you were talk to dad do you think
that my step I wouldn't believe that
you're human she loves hentai how many
years did you spend learning design in
college did you get a job in designing
by the way I studied engineering do you
take your job seriously why or why not
this does look like a [ __ ] surface are
you a Christian um yes how do you eat
your cereal like a normal person can you
write a poem for me senpai okay let me
see here
roses are red violets are blue eat a
dick
what do you think about that it's very
sexual see this is how you know it's art
when when you look at it and you you're
just like I can't explain I can't
explain all these emotions what if you
had three nipples yeah what if that all
the questions asked fields what has been
the weirdest question you've gotten
while they're all weird I can't get
normal questions for some and some
reason what's laying out backwards
alright that's it
thank you for watching this video thumbs
up this video so I can feel better about
myself now wait no one's gonna thumbs up
then thumbs up this video so you will
feel better about yourself [ __ ] it I
have a headache today I'm sorry this was
probably the worst video ever
I didn't even hurts to live I don't
thanks for watching
frontier my friend that will see you
browse in the next one come over offer
I'm still here alive in a person's shoes
for a day so I present to you a day in
the pound with my great love bear and
poo so I like to wake up